you mentioned a bird bath what's a bird
bath bird bath is when you're not
allowed to go take a real shower cause
they're cause you know you can't come
out of your cell so you got a shower
with that sink in that toilet that you
got right there you know what i mean you
put towels towards the door
kind of stop the water from going out
onto the tier because nobody likes water
on your tear you know what i'm saying
people try to fish people try to walk
through there they can't because there's
a puddle of water and soap which is
nasty it's all your dirt water
so you you know you put up the towels a
certain way to where
you see which way the water goes so if
the water comes this way you make sure
that part is is blocked in so the water
stays in your cell
you know you put up a sheet or a blanket
whatever it is to cover your cells or
your celly ain't watching you wash your
ass you know what i mean of course soap
up you know throw you get a cup water
you know pour water all over yourself
soap up whatever you can and the same
thing you fill up your sink
where you put a little piece of maybe i
don't know envelope or whatever that'll
hold the little holes down so the water
don't go down
fill up the sink with the water then
you're just dunking your cup and just
pouring it over yourself you make sure
you shower yeah it's a shower but it's
called a bird bath you know what i'm
saying so it smells like [ __ ] then after
that you get your your
towels you pick up all that dirt water
and just wring it all out into your
toilet you know it's it's it's a little
hassle but once you learn how to do it
and they're refreshing
you know what i mean you're clean you
can lay back on your bed and smell good
like you know and then you would do that
only if you were under lockdown right
which a lot of the times we were so
sometimes that was almost every day
because i think they'll give you a
shower like every 72 hours 72 hours like
72 hours
and
it's like i'm not going to sit there and
wait for those 70 talk two hours you're
gonna smell crazy
that's why you get that program you
clean yourself
you know one day he cleaned it one day i
clean it one day he like you know we
take turns and [ __ ] and it's a it's like
i said the respect level is a lot better
when you're in you know
places like that what happens if you get
a cellmate and it doesn't work out you
don't get along with them
is it like
like what happens then um it's like a
forced roommate you can't even vet the
guy like yeah i mean it all depends you
know what i'm saying there's certain
ways of going about it and getting you
know your rooms
moved around and you know what i'm
saying you put with somebody you're a
little bit more compatible with or
somebody you know from the streets like
myself i
kind of refrained from having my own
homies in the cell because at the time i
felt like
you know after a little while your own
homies get comfortable you know what i
mean like they know you from the streets
they love you and it's like they get
real comfortable they might slack on the
day they're supposed to clean this out
it is you know so i kind of just so that
we could keep that same love and same
respect like i said up with other dudes
that you know what i mean i didn't know
like that so that way the respect stays
stays there that's interesting you know